[Music]
walter mitty is a character who has
lived in Hollywood for decades others in
1947 movie there's the theater
adaptations why did you think now was a
time to revisit him I read the script
that Steve wrote Steve Conrad wrote and
it was I thought it was really good
and it was it I'd read a script Ben sent
it I got sent it as an actor first and
I've gotten a script about eight or nine
years ago another version of it that was
really trying to remake the original
musical comedy but without music and it
just didn't seem like there was a way to
top that movie because it's just you
know it's a classic musical comedy it's
a genre that I think was done better
than than it is now and and so I I
didn't think it was something I felt I
could do and then I got Steve script and
I think he was willing to sort of you
know look at it from a different point
of view and tell this story that to me
related a lot to the original short
story that James Thurber wrote in 1939
which is just a really short like I
think it's like six or seven pages story
about a guy going run errands with his
wife and he has all these fantasies in
his head while he's running errands and
that's basically all it is but there's a
melancholy and a sort of nobility to the
character that comes through that made
that character iconic and became sort of
synonymous with the daydreamer
and that emotion I felt was in Steve
script and I thought he was is by
placing it in this you know environment
of the work space that was being
downsized and the idea of a sort of
digital world is going analog world is
going digital it felt very in that that
felt very relevant to me and I think it
just he approached the characters more
he was more interested in why the guy
was a daydreamer and and the idea of
this guy trying to connect with his true
self and that the daydreams were coming
out of this idea of who he wanted to be
and he wasn't daydreaming of himself
being someone else he was really
daydreaming of himself as someone a
better version of himself and that felt
very emotionally connected to me and so
that I think that's why I wanted to do
it in terms of selling it to the to the
studio everybody was just very much
behind it
once once they began to see what what
the film was going to be and in terms of
just selling it I think everybody wants
to see a good movie
and I think that that the idea of
something not being able to be kind of
compartmentalized or limited is an asset
that's those are the kinds of movies
that I like to see and and I think that
the fact that it can't be distilled into
a limerick or an ad line or something
that that's a you know that has a number
on it I I think that that that that
stands for something and it's it's a
it's I like going to see something where
I don't know what it's going to be are
they saying it's a comedy are they
saying it's trouble I don't know how to
describe it
ya know I mean I you know right from the
start we talked about it not necessarily
fitting into one Jean or the other I
think that was in Steve script you know
that he and that's been a lot of his
work as a writer he writes a really
funny sort of dark cynical stuff but
then is also really emotional and minoo
he intentionally structured the
screenplay as to not really go in the
direction that a typical movie of this
may be you know even the genre of an you
know action comedy or whatever that or
an adventure comedy or whatever I don't
even know what that means but you know
in terms of like building to a third act
that like got bigger and bigger you know
his actually like build it to a third
act that got smaller and smaller and I
actually love that about the script and
Kristen I'm curious from a performance
standpoint do you think about the
fantasy sequences differently than you
think about the reality sequences should
I be some sort of heightened version of
this character yeah well we had talked
about that and I know they were even
shot differently right like as far as
like it was like that not the film but
like you said something was different
yeah well we well I mean the whole idea
was that you know Walter's living in you
know the world that he's in is sort of
you know he's in a world that's sort of
rigid and
you know not as full and not as free as
where it ends up going and so just
that's you know visually we tried to
emphasize that so the fantasies were
looser and more colorful and shot
anamorphic for the fantasies and flat
screen for the other stuff and then
eventually went to a noir for the rest
of the movie but you know stylistically
the thing that's great about Kristen
creatively what's great about her is
that she can do all different things you
know all different types of acting I
mean she's really that's why I wanted
her to play the role because I felt you
know there was it was very challenging
to establish a relationship between
Walter and Sheryl in the amount of time
personally they don't even have a
relationship and there's very there's a
very little time for them to connect in
any way before he goes off into the
world and you had to really as an
audience want
I felt want them to know see these two
people sort of be rooting for them to
get together but also believe that why
Walter would like her why she would like
Walter and I felt you know an audience
already invests in Kristen and I knew
she was a really good actress aside from
her comedic genius she is you know in
what you did in bridesmaids was you know
kind of did everything which was just
like anchor the movie and be very real
but also really funny too and in this I
knew that in the fantasy she'd be able
to like just you know she can tweak
something just a little bit you know and
she has such a great sense of timing and
and how to make something just a little
bit you know pushed that we had I've had
fun working on those things with you
because you could just she's like just
so delicate and you can just turn turn
it up like one you know notch at a time
because a lot of people named Bjorn in
the credits a nice benefit of shooting
in Iceland it's a popular name you also
shot in New York and not on a soundstage
only in New York that is clearly New
York City is it hard to shoot in New
York nowadays and in the middle of the
business day like that yes would be
shooting scenes and people would drive
I'd look Ben Stiller like
I love doing yeah you have to you have
to do it you can't recreate New York at
all and it was you know right right by
30 rock and we were just like walking
right by there and shooting the scene
and it was was amazing yeah I mean a lot
of people are not extras ya know we
actually wanted to do that I wanted to
try to get shots where we didn't have
just extras in it because I feel like
you again that's something you can feel
a lot of the time and to take advantage
of the energy out of New York Street on
6th Avenue that to me I wanted to get
that because it reminded me of movies
that I Love New York in the 70s or a lot
of movies where they just shoot on the
streets and you know you could tell that
there were they weren't closing the
streets down or anything or I kept on
thinking of the opening to the odd
couple in the TV series when they're
walking down the street New York that's
just that's the thing I'd like but so we
actually went on you know 6th Avenue
came walking down and just left it kind
of opened a some people that were extras
you know for continuity but basically a
lot of those people are real and I feel
like that I like seeing that having that
energy and that's the only type of thing
you can only do in New York you shot
this on film
yes how come well it's a movie about a
guy trying to find a negative right and
I know chemically I you know it just
felt right to me and I love film I I oh
I always want to shoot movies on film
you know just I feel like it's that's I
just I think it looks better I like how
it looks and yeah this in this movie to
me it was all about a guy who cared
about film and I just felt like it was
how do you direct and star in a movie
like this what is that like I've
approached this a few times you know
I've done it a few times over the years
it doesn't really get easier but you do
see that the challenges ahead and and
you just try to kind of address them
ahead of time for me it's about prepping
as much as possible we were lucky enough
to have a very long prep on the movie
wealth of Studios figuring out if they
wanted to actually make it so I had time
to storyboard and to previz and to
really do so much of that work so that
really it all comes down to when you're
shooting on the day that you can demote
devote as much time to the actors I feel
like the two challenges are you know
being there for the other actors as a
director when you're in it it's
extremely important that they feel that
there's a director on the set who's
watching them it's not obsessing over
his own thing and then kind of giving
yourself a break as an actor
knowing how frustrated you're going to
be with yourself because you're acting
and you're stuck with yourself as an
actor and you know you wish you had a
different director but you you know but
you decided to do this so it's really
like trying to give give give myself as
much leeway thinking you know a year
down the line when I'm in the editing
room that I want to have as many options
as possible so it's kind of a it's never
it's never efficient necessarily and
it's sometimes frustrating you rely on
people that you're close to
you know stewards an important I that I
you know well I'll ask his opinion on
things it's really trying to figure out
you know how to balance that all and
keep the keep it all moving forward and
keeping your own insecurities to
yourself a little bit so that you don't
freak out the other actor it wasn't it
was amazing to watch I have to say I
mean the film like you said alone is
very ambitious and to have him be I'm
going to talk about you know have him be
directing and just so organized and
focused on all the things that he wanted
to do and now he wanted the movie to
look and sound and feel like and then
step in front of the camera and just
really be there with you like in the
scene with you right there and then just
go back and direct and have something to
say about the sets and then just be
there as a friend I mean it was it was
really inspiring for me to watch that
this movie is all about a daydreamer who
takes it into the real world I do any of
you consider yourself day dreamers I've
say I know I've enjoyed the life that
I've been living for so you know for a
while so I don't sit there and go oh I
wish I was this I wish I was that you
know I I I'm pretty satisfied with where
I am he is the most interesting man what
about you Ben do you consider yourself
MIDI yes I probably am in that I sort of
go off in my head a lot I obviously
think you know when you're making a
movie or you're thinking about it all
the time and in the that's for me you
know for like whatever the it's been
almost three years from when we really
started on this thing you know just
thinking about it that's where I'll go
you know if I'm if I'm dinner or
something or with somebody I'll start
thinking about a scene that we're trying
to fix or a scene that we're editing
especially I'm editing I think I'll day
dream about the movie because and also
that's what making a movie is it's
really envisioning it in your head and
thinking about it all the time until you
get it on film
that's that's what making a movie is
you're picturing it you're thinking
about it and it's a great place to go